the pope
is a special unit of the military police
of rio de janeiro state
in brazil due to the extreme nature of
crime
and the largest city slums boppa units
have extensive experience in urban
warfare combat
and progression in confined and
restricted environments
it is one of the most efficient troops
in urban combat in the world
bope operates in extreme risk operations
whether in patrolling high-risk sites
fighting in places of difficult access
hostage incidents
and situations of confrontation with
drug dealers
the boppa was created on january 19 1978
as nucleus of the society of special
operations through a project developed
and presented by the then captain of the
military police
their logo is known in brazil as whaka
nakhthira
portuguese for knife in the skull
the knife in the skull symbolizes their
motto victory over death
and the cross pistols are the symbol of
the military police
pope has gained notoriety due to their
role in the violent war on drugs
and have been referred to as death squad
boppay currently perform a number of
roles including
extermination of drug trafficking
infections serving high risk
arrest warrants hostage rescue
suppression of prison riots
providing superior assault firepower in
combat situations
special missions in swamps or mountain
terrains such as reconnaissance
planning and infiltration and resolving
high-risk situations with a minimum loss
of life
injury or property damage
to join the pope a candidate must be in
the military police for at least two
years
they must have a high level of fitness
as well as being able to pass scrolling
physical
medical and psychological assessments
the reactivation of team rainbow in 2015
two pope operators were recruited to
bring their skills and expertise
to assist in the fight against terrorism
on a global scale
these operators were named capital and
[Music]
[Music]
kavita
overloaded
is an attacking operator in team rainbow
born in navway wasu a city within the
state of rio de janeiro in brazil
capitao is the youngest of three
children
raised in a close-knit community held
together by similar social and cultural
ties
there was a lot of support and unity
among the people as everyone tried their
best to help each other where they could
and tried to keep the children out of
gangs and off the street
but ultimately no place was ever truly
safe and soon tragedy and loss
burrowed its way into the sousa family
tearing one of the eldest boys
ruthlessly from this world his murderers
a group of drug dealers with little
remorse of the families they tear apart
time and time again this event would
forever shape the choices and actions
for this family
and no one more so than capital
driven by an intense desire to protect
the people closest to him
he entered the palesia militare where he
trained in a wide range of tactical
weapons
and breaching strategies although he's
very tight-lipped about his past
liaisons
he obviously had a close relationship at
some point as he is the father
of three children his eldest is named
after his brother who passed away
and often the family share stories about
his exploits growing up in order to keep
his memory alive
capitaeo continues the same traditions
that he himself grew up with
family first safer communities together
and open and honest communication with
his children
although he may come across as a little
overbearing at times he struggles to
trust their friends
which is most likely why he encourages
them all to congregate at his home
where he can keep an eye on them he
knows he has raised them to be kind
aware and smart about the choices they
make in their lives
it's more that he has an intense fear of
losing them even more so than other
parents
because of how he tragically lost his
brother he understands that in his line
of work
and in their neighborhood that no one no
matter what is ever truly safe
over time capitaeo took part in a number
of dangerous operations
against the criminal cartel and became a
renowned expert
on the organization and their
psychological behaviour
unfortunately for him on one of their
routine raids on the cartel
he was ambushed and taken hostage
what occurred during those two months of
his capture before he was rescued
obviously had a momentous impact on his
psyche
although he never talks about the
torture and brutal treatment inflicted
on him
he forever sports momentum from his
captors a mutilated eye socket
forged by their actions what the cartel
failed to realize was by not killing him
once again they had unintentionally
helped solidify his relentlessness
his dedication to justice and protecting
those who cannot protect themselves
and fundamentally a soldier hell-bent on
destroying them
when he was first rescued there was talk
about removing him from the field
operations
but it soon became clear to his
superiors that doing this would be a
huge disservice to cappateau
believing capitao perfectly embodied
their motto victory over death
and given his urban warfare experience
pope recruited him into their ranks
following his recovery although the
cartel had placed a bounty on his head
he is not deterred he has a purpose and
while this may be a daunting task for
one member of law enforcement to try and
fix alone
he will do everything in his power to
find their weakness destroy their
infrastructure
and bring them down for good
it is clear that boppa made a clever
call when offering capitaio a place on
their team
as is exceptional drive and years of
unique experiences
make him an invaluable asset to any unit
an excellent operator dedicated focused
analytical
every step of every decision he makes
reinforces his commitment to protecting
his family
and making their world safer however he
struggles to maintain some distance
between his role as a protector
and the characteristics that define his
personality fortunately
his teammate kevira understands this and
endeavors in ensuring that he remains
grounded
cappateo is equipped with a tactical
crossbow attack mark zero
this weapon flies a glass bolt without
alerting hostiles to the user's position
the glass cartridge breaks on impact
releasing a gas that ignites the oxygen
in the surrounding area
it fires two types of ammunition
asphyxiating bolts and micro smoke
grenades
the asphyxiating bolts burn the oxygen
in a given perimeter which is lethal to
the target
the micro smoke grenades enable the user
to mask movement
without alerting opponents of their
position
i'm coming for you
tana pereira codenamed kevita is a
defending operator in team rainbow
kavira was born in the small town of
renopolis in the state of sao polo
unfortunately her father died before she
was born and her mother only received a
small sum of money after his death
which meant the family was forced to
move to a poorer neighborhood in rio de
janeiro
while she is very close with her
siblings as the only girl out of 10
she has had to learn to fight to be
heard and even be noticed a lot of the
time
as a result kaveta is often criticized
for being blunt by those who don't
understand
large family dynamics their mother is a
strong woman
but understandably she was often
exhausted distracted
and because of this her children had to
learn to be strong independent
resourceful and resilient fortunately
they also lived with a grandmother
a sharp disciplinarian who had an
uncanny ability to see through the
deceptions and games
gavita learned a lot from the family's
matriarch and has immense respect for
her
a strong powerful woman although looking
at her you wouldn't think so
she helped hone kavita's interrogation
skills gifted her her first knife
and always kept her on her toes still
life is tough when you're poor and
growing up in the streets of rio de
janeiro
you're constantly fighting to be heard
fighting to survive and fighting for a
chance
and eventually those fights and those
chances that everyone around you is also
competing for
start to wear you down and you start to
look for easier ways to get the things
you need
even if it's against the law so as a
consequence
when she was 16 years old she was
arrested on burglary charges
when presented to the judge for a
sentencing he was impressed by her calm
and collected manner
and gave her the option of either
juvenile reformatory or working with the
boppay as an informant
she believed by joining bopay that they
would support and encourage her to
continue in cultivating her devious
tendencies
which would serve them and also herself
while undercover
this proved to be a good choice for her
as years of undercover operations within
brazil's notorious gangs
made her a master of surveillance and
interrogation techniques
eventually the judge's mandatory time
she had to serve came to an end
but she could no longer see herself
doing anything else she had finally
found her place in the world
and so she quickly re-enlisted with
bopay
recognized as an expert in the field she
often found herself called upon when
conducting training exercises within the
force
rainbow formally invited cavita to join
them in 2016
as a result of a key role as an
interrogator during the 2010 rio de
janeiro security crisis
although she had undermined bopay
protocol they were not deterred
in 2019 caveira went awol and killed
several santa blanca gang members
this was in response to them kidnapping
her brother after his cover was blown
and it was discovered that he was
working for the federal police of brazil
valkyrie and twitch collaborated with
ghost recon to recover her
in an enterprise by the name of
operation archangel
although it's fair to say that while the
mission was a success they caused
tension between kevira and valkyrie
not one to think before she acts
especially when a family member is in
danger
kevita along with her actions could have
potentially started an international
incident
and valkyrie being the straight-laced
and impeccable soldier that she is
would have struggled with caviar's
rebellious nature and if push came to
shove
she would have done whatever it took to
accomplish the mission
as a complete polar opposite the
affinity between cavetta and twitch
is far more friendly they met back in
2016 and although the connection is
clearly very strong
their relationship status is unknown
comms between the two show that they
spend time outside of work together
although twitch would prefer they go out
in public more rather than just staying
at home
over time kavita has developed a
predatory stealth technique
called the silent step this allows her
to lurk on her prey
in almost complete silence until it's
too late
gavira's ability allows her to sneak up
on a target swiftly immobilize them
and force him to divulge the position of
the opposing team
although i still thoroughly enjoy these
stories interest in them certainly seems
to be waning
so let me know in the comments if you'd
like me to continue with these i'm easy
either way
otherwise thank you very much for
watching and i'll catch you in the next
one cheers
you